hey this is fresh tall Walker a single
alien lands on earth every day after
that each alien on earth undergoes a
transformation which could be any of the
four equally likely events the alien
could die the alien could do nothing the
alien could replicate itself which means
there are two aliens in total or the
alien could replicate itself two times
which means there are three aliens total
what is the probability the alien race
eventually dies out and goes extinct
this question is sometimes asked as an
interview question for technical jobs
can you figure it out give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the solution
let's write P for the probability that
an alien and all of its descendants die
out the probability that one alien and
all of its descendants die out is P the
next day there are four equally likely
events there is a 25% chance that this
alien could die out this means there's a
conditional probability of one that this
alien and all of its descendants die out
there is another contingency or the
alien does nothing now the situation is
exactly the same this means the
probability is still P that this alien
and all of its descendants will die out
there's also a 25% chance the alien will
replicate itself so that there are two
aliens now each of these aliens will
have a probability P that this alien and
all of its descendants will die out each
of these lines of aliens will be
independent from each other the
probability that both of them
and all of their descendants I out will
be the product P times P equals P
squared in the final 25% case the alien
replicates itself two times each of
these aliens has a probability P of
dying out and having all of their
descendants die out each of these
branches is independent from each other
the probability that all three die out
will be equal to P times P times P which
is P cubed if the probability is to
exist it must satisfy the following
equation the probability of an alien and
all of its descendants dying out has to
be equal to 0.25 times the quantity 1
plus P plus P squared plus P cubed in
the theory of statistical branching
processes the probability of extinction
is equal to the smallest positive root
of this equation this is equal to the
square root of 2 minus 1 which is
approximately 41.4% and that's the
answer now to be comprehensive we should
consider the other solutions to this
equation one solution is negative and
that can be disregarded because a
probability cannot be negative but the
other solution is equal to 1 this would
mean there's a probability of 1 that
it's surely going to happen that the
aliens would go extinct how do we know
that this is not the solution and that
the correct solution is 41.4% to figure
that out we have to dig deeper into the
details and consider the discrete
version of the problem let's write P sub
K for the probability of an alien and
all of its descendants dying out in K
days let's consider the probability that
an alien dies out in k plus 1 days there
are four things that can happen the next
day there's a 25% chance the alien dies
out
in which case the conditional
probability of dying out in K plus-1
days is equal to one there's a 25%
chance the alien does nothing now one
day has already passed so in order for
this alien and all of its descendants to
die out in K plus-1 days the next day
this alien and all of its descendants
would have to die out in K days it would
have to be one day less the conditional
probability here is P sub K in the 25%
chance the alien replicates itself so
there are two aliens each of these
aliens and all of their descendants
would have to die out in K days this is
a conditional probability of P sub K
squared in the final case the alien
replicates itself two times and each of
these aliens and have a P sub K chance
that that alien and all of its
descendants would die out in K days the
probability of all of them dying out
would be the product which is P sub K
cubed now one thing to notice here is
that the expected number of aliens the
next day is equal to zero plus one plus
two plus three all divided by four this
is equal to 1.5 which is greater than
one that means the alien is more than
replicating itself on average so we can
expect that there's a chance the aliens
would survive the probability of
extinction should not be equal to one it
should be less than one
so how do we know this is true we have
this recursive equation for the
probability the alien dies out in k plus
one days in terms of the probability
that it would die out in K days we're
going to show that this probability is
always less than or equal to the square
root of two minus one now what's the
probability an alien would die out in
exactly one day well that's only the 25%
chance that it simply dies out in the
following day this is our base case now
we assume this is true for all values
less than or equal less than P sub K
plus
one so we have this recurrence relation
and we can now apply the induction
hypothesis on all the terms piece of
clay so we'll substitute in square root
of 2 minus 1 for those terms and this
all simplifies to be square root of 2
minus 1 so we have an increasing
sequence of P sub K because the
probability keeps increasing as we
expand the number of days this is an
increasing sequence and we know it's
bounded by square root of 2 minus 1 so
in fact this sequence will converge to
the value of square root of 2 minus 1
and that in fact is the correct answer
to this problem did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on Facebook Google+ and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at pressure soccer and if you like this
video please check out my books there
links in the video description